en México desde septiembre de 2021 la
suprema corte de justicia de la nación
determinó que es inconstitucional
criminalizar la interrupción del
embarazo en aquella ocasión por
unanimidad los ministros despenalizaron
el aborto no obstante aún a la fecha hay
algunos estados de la República Mexicana
que mantienen en sus legislaciones penas
para quien interrumpa el embarazo pero
ahora la primera sala de la suprema
corte resolvió que cualquier mujer o
persona con capacidad de gestar tiene
legitimidad para recurrir mediante la
vía del Amparo a impugnar los artículos
de legislaciones estatales que penalizan
el aborto en su resolución los ministros
establecieron que no es necesario que la
mujer o persona gestante se encuentra
embarazada para poder recurrir al Amparo
es decir no se exige la aplicación de
los artículos para que puedan ser
impugnados en su argumentación los
ministros establecieron que estas normas
que en el aborto contribuyen a generar
un imaginario social adverso basado en
estereotipos discriminatorios que pueden
obstaculizar el acceso a la protección
de los Derechos Humanos a la vida a la
integridad personal y a la autonomía
reproductiva también pueden generar
temor entre los médicos lo que puede
derivar en desigualdad Al momento de
proveer servicios de salud tras este
fallo algunos colectivos feministas
celebraron que una vez más la suprema
corte va un paso más adelante que los
propios legisladores